now vietnam is one of the world's top
four countries for shoe manufacturing
much of that is down to factories
pumping out pairs for big brands like
nike and adidas but a fashion revival
means some shoemakers are putting their
hearts and souls into a revolutionary
design
a new trend is gaining traction
rubber sandals like these ones are
becoming fashionable again
the sandals were first made in the 1940s
during the indochina war against the
french
they were crafted from ambushed military
truck tires
today they're made in a variety of
styles to appeal to a much wider
audience
we want the rubber sandals to become
part of our heritage
they're one of the
the sandals were popularized by former
revolutionary leader ho chi minh and by
vietcong soldiers during the vietnam war
they became a symbol of the communist
state's resourcefulness
during wartime
now during peacetime they've come to
represent sustainable design and
reducing one's carbon footprint
i myself prefer handmade sandals because
they're cheaper
we can use old tires to make the rubber
sandals
of course we could just as easily make
rubber sandals from new rubber
but
hanoi shop a pair sells for around 10
euro his brand has sold more than half a
million pairs since he took over his
father-in-law's business 11 years ago
for a small young company that's quite a
feat